[Musique]
non les romands aujourd'hui stéphanie à
nîmes en solo pour la première fois une
visite de découverte de la médiathèque
du tango depuis trois mois la jeune
femme est en service civique au sein de
cette structure
comme beaucoup de jeunes elle est sortie
des études un peu perdu et sans
compétences lui permettant de trouver
rapidement sa place sur le marché du
travail
elle se tourne alors vers un service
civique pour se remettre le pied à
l'étrier et poursuivre un vieux rêve de
de base moi je m'étais dit après ma
licence que ce serait bien que je me
réoriente dans un métier du livre
donc je me suis dit que faire un service
civique en adéquation avec les métiers
les métiers du livre de la culture voilà
la médiation culturelle tout ça ça
pouvait à être en plus au sein de la
médiathèque du sundgau
stéphanie découvre les activités
quotidiennes des bibliothécaires mais
aussi d'autres aspects plus méconnus de
leur métier
ces missions portent principalement sur
des actions de médiation culturelle
elle est amenée à nous aider à créer des
animations et ensuite à animer des
groupes notamment des groupes de
personnes
dit empêché dans le milieu des
bibliothèques donc ce sont des personnes
qui pour une raison ou une autre sont
éloignés du monde des bibliothèques
ça peut être parce qu'elles sont
porteuses d'un handicap psychique ou
mental ça peut être parce que il ya déjà
à la base un souci de d'accès à la
culture à la lecture
ça peut être aussi parce qu'elles ne
peuvent pas se déplacer
donc on accueille des effectivement
différentes institutions comme les ime
on peut être amené à les en ehpad on va
aussi à la deçà de ferrette pour
effectivement proposer des animations à
tous ces publics
alexis est lui aussi en service civique
à la médiathèque du sundgau
le jeune homme donne aujourd'hui un
cours d'informatique contrairement à
stéphanie il n'avait jamais envisagé de
travailler en bibliothèque met lui aussi
en galère dans sa recherche d'un premier
emploi a sauté sur l'offre que lui
proposait la structure départementale
je suis ambassadeur du numérique pour
tous qui animation numérique
enfin tout ce qui est tout ce qu ils ont
informatique la passe il n'y a pas très
longtemps je donne des cours
d'informatique sun maintenant un mois
j'étais accompagné mansion 2 bensen à
des personnes qui ont du mal avec
l'informatique ont peur entre guillemets
et puis après je gère tout ce qui
m'était médias je deviens et bientôt je
n'aurais des cours dans les autres
bibliothèques sur notre site caillé 68
pour leur apprendre comment ça
fonctionne à quoi ça sert qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec
créée en 2010 le service civique c'est
l'opportunité pour des jeunes de 16 à 25
ans de réaliser une mission d'intérêt
général auprès d'une association d'une
collectivité ou encore d'un
établissement public
l'engagement dure de six à douze mois et
est indemnisé environ 580 euros par mois
attention le volontaire n'est ni un
stagiaire ni un salarié le cadre de ses
missions est clairement défini ils ne
sont pas là pour faire notre travail ou
pour effectivement remplacé où nous
aider à faire des missions qui nous
incombent et ils doivent vraiment
remplir des missions qui à la base
n'existe pas ou qui n'ont pas encore été
créé
donc nous effectivement on a des idées
donc on a des choses on a plein d'envié
on ne peut pas tout faire donc à partir
de là on a créé des missions pour
répondre à des besoins et à des demandes
rencontrant un succès grandissant auprès
des jeunes le service civique se
développe peu à peu et s'inscrit dans
les parcours de vie certains venant
chercher une première expérience
d'autres une découverte ou encore des
compétences nous sommes là pour les
aider
concernant leur projet professionnel
mais notre but principal c'est que
lorsqu'il ressort de ce service l'x et
qui se sent grandi qui est des nouvelles
compétences qui n'avaient pas forcément
où justement qu'ils aient pu aller
prolongé et les développer et d'un autre
côté nous apprenons s'est énormément
d'eux comme disait ma collègue ben c'est
un regard neuf et c'est que du positif
[Musique]
alexis et stéphanie deux parcours
différents mais tous deux témoignent
d'une expérience positive
ça n'a pas beaucoup de choses de jeu de
préparer et d'organiser une animation
par exemple d'un autre par un cours en
avance on apprend plein de choses en
services inc je trouve ça bien je crois
commandes totalement de faire un service
civique
parce que ça amène des compétences ça
amène une insertion même minime dans le
travail c'est toujours un plus dans un
cv on retrouve nos deux jeunes avec les
six autres volontaires des différents
services du conseil départemental
aujourd'hui tous rencontre brigitte
klinkert pour faire le point à mi
parcours de leur engagement
c'est la toute première année que
l'institution départementale recrute des
volontaires pour cette promotion on est
donc dans l'expérimentation mais on
souhaite en tout cas que cette
expérience soit la plus profitable
possible aux jeunes engagés en service
civique c'est la construction d'un
projet personnel
et ce personnel c'est ce sont les
missions qui sont confiées aux jeunes
volontaires mais ce sont aussi des
formations qui sont proposés à ces
jeunes volontaires comme par exemple
dans le domaine du secours à à la
personne mais également et nous allons
expérimenter cette année au conseil
départemental des cours d'allemand pour
ceux qui le souhaitent voir d'autres
cours en fonction des besoins qui sont
les leurs en tout cas il y as au conseil
départemental du haut rhin un droit à la
formation pour les jeunes service
civique au conseil départemental
après cette première expérience très
réussie on souhaite développer le
dispositif service civique pour l'année
prochaine l'institution souhaite
proposer un plus grand nombre d'offres